speaking of animatronic willies have you
seen willy's wonderland
no they have not great segue i have not
seen it but heard nicholas cage
had it had a sick hairline in that
he absolutely kills it in that movie
literally
what do you mean he kills the movie out
of that movie
what does that mean uh he's doing murder
in that movie lots
oh i see okay he's killing people no
the premise is that he's
he's a traveler by the way this full
whole movie it's wait spoiled alert are
we doing spoiler alert here
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm not going to
watch this movie because it seems like
it's awful not really
no you you need to watch this movie oh
my god bro
take three shots of anything and watch
this movie okay
you're gonna have i'm telling if there's
any movie that you watch in the next
seven days it's this one
you're gonna laugh your [ __ ] ass off
okay
this movie makes you feel so good in so
many different ways you know
kyle and i joked that this movie got
like a six or a four but
i take that statement back this movie
gets a hundred okay
because it makes you feel so good about
yourself
it makes you feel like you you be like
you can become an actor okay
it makes you feel like nicholas cage
might
do your movie got it you know
yeah it's just you watch this and you're
like anyone
anyone could be a filmmaker anyone could
be an actor
i could make a better movie than this
with zero dollars
not not so judgmental it's more like
damn
they're selling this for 20 and i bought
it [ __ ] anything's possible
okay that's by the end of that movie
you're like this you're like
i i could fight mayweather
what's the general what's the general
plot so the premise is
nicholas cage plays a plays a traveling
man
okay and his car breaks down in the
middle of a town
he's sort of like a nomad type guy yeah
okay
nomad camaro guy okay oh
hardcore yeah and so
um you know his his car him and his car
get picked up
because it's obviously broken
now he doesn't have any cash and the
eight the only atm in town is broken
so what would you do to work off the um
you know money that is owed on the car
that's broken
you would go right or you know you would
go
work overnight cleaning an old chuck e
cheese
okay yeah right that's what i would do
yeah
that's the offer presented to him by the
town you know
and it's the most hilarious [ __ ] that
scene is so good where he's like you got
any cash
and nick cage looks at the only it's one
atm
in the mechanics shop and it says broken
okay oh it's broken
dang looks like you had to work it off
so they take him to willy's wonderland
hold on and this is a
deserted chuck e cheese like do they use
it anymore well
they still do so you find out as willy's
wonderland is
a bit haunted and the animatronic
machines
in there come to life and they try to
kill nick cage
what oh my god dude
how is nick cage is just he's so broke
that he just keeps doing these stupid
ass like how could you ever read the
script for that and be like
yeah this is gonna be good for my career
at this point
you know what man i thought that when we
started diving deep that guy does a [ __ ]
load of movies
oh he's just trying to make his money
back i'm pretty sure he's been bankrupt
for like
years dude you just read that article
how he blew 125 million a year
in a [ __ ] year how do you even hear
that's hard to do
oh it is you think yeah do you think
but that article proves that you can
blow these
that article proves to me billionaires
don't try hard enough
how do you even spend that much what was
he spending it on dude he's bought like
weird uh man let me let me just pull it
up
nicholas cage two guys on the computer
um 125 mil
yeah 150 million
159 this guy's my idol
like here because one one another thing
is that like
you could lose that you could lose that
much with
bad investments you know what i'm saying
that's definitely
that's definitely uh like uh a valid way
to lose a bunch of money but it's also
like
you're striving to earn more money right
how do you spend 150 million dollars
that's
hard to do let me show you okay
uh he bought an island in the bahamas
okay
he bought two castles in europe okay
uh he bought a mansion in new orleans
okay he bought shrunken pygmy heads
i mean he bought a um nine foot tall
burial tomb yeah it's got to go with the
why would you do that apparently 150k on
a pet octopus
he bought the first superman comic and
he bought a 70 million year old dinosaur
skull
276 thousand and it turned out to be
stolen
and cage had to return it to the
mongolian government
oh my god so it's just a few things
that's a bad investment right there
that's what that is yeah
yeah how did he not have a business
manager
sitting there going like hey yeah yeah
yeah
all right we got the island we got the
castles
i don't think they don't need the pygmy
heads yeah
and nick cage is like the heads have to
go in the castle
right right it's bad luck if they're not
in the castle do you not get that
no the tomb is because of mommy the
mummy
you know it's bad luck not to have a
tomb in your place
yeah yeah so that remind me did you that
was brandon frazier sorry you guys
you know you just you tend to blend with
me sometimes with your movies
i was going to say you did the mummy but
uh yeah but i just love it i love
that movie so much that i had to get the
tune no i know i know i know i'm such a
big fan of
i know nick that's nicholas cage you
know i know he's such a big fan of
brennan fraser
bro nick national treasure that's the
one i was going for
yeah nick case doesn't have a single
line in willy's wonderland
what do you mean let's um he doesn't
have a line like he doesn't speak
why not why not
it's just his character he just screams
that's it
he doesn't the whole movie is
holy [ __ ] nope that's why he took that
script
he was like hold on i get to make how
much
i don't i don't say anything yeah
that's what i said they handed in that
script that she just said sunglasses
like all right nick your character's
gonna wear sunglasses and then they're
gonna come off
and then you're gonna have to kill some
people he was like nice
i would do that i would definitely do
that run it
dude
come on man like i don't i if you know
if we get pneuma i don't want my dick
looking like whatever the equivalent
is of this in 40 years you know
dude it looks like it looks like
someone's kneecap
like like you see like his fort like his
head
is like the shape of someone's kneecap
you know what i mean like
this is what i see yeah it's just
it's just wild it's like clearly
i don't know what i don't know what it
is this is what i always wonder like if
you're thinning
and you get hair plugs like if you say
you're thinning in the middle so that's
where they put the plugs
but then you keep aging and you keep
thinning elsewhere like why didn't they
do
this area too yeah like in other
pictures you can see it's
just in the middle of his head and it
just sprouts out like a like a palm tree
and there's no hair like up until like
the first two thirds of his head are
just
bald yo calculus majors um
here's your home is your tmg homework
calculate the arc
on his hairline right there
and if that arc can be applied to
basketball
i believe that's the arc you need to
land a free throw shot
i think the mathematics
on his [ __ ] hairline can be applied
to that
and quite possibly race car driving i
actually think that is the same line you
take
on on on a corner in a race you know
what else
it could be the nike swoosh under under
uh like upside down
yes i think that's the exact curve
how's that for intellectual humor you
[ __ ] bozo
you know who i'm talking about you know
i'm talking to you bro
i think we're just more bullying this
guy
yeah we are i'm sorry for his appearance
i think that's
more like what we're doing not really
that's definitely what we're doing
yeah no you're right but okay complain
keep pausing
away just real quick no wait hold on if
you follow the line from his hairline
down to his beard
i believe that's half the track pattern
for
uh monza i believe that's half of a
formula one track i think you could
match that to half of a formula one
track all right let's get using using
the photoshop pen tool on this would be
easy as [ __ ]
jeez all right i'm sorry hey and look it
mine's not the greatest either man i got
it i got a little swoop there too you
know what i'm saying so really
wonderland
i will pay to have your card fixed
you are officially let's get the hell
out of here
i can't stand to hear a grown man scream
this place has a dark history
i know the [ __ ] story they told you
it's a lie
you're here to be a human sacrifice
have you been listening to a word i've
been saying
he's gonna die in here but he won't
listen to me
what the [ __ ]
dudes what the [ __ ] it's like the worst
oh you need to watch this dude
oh my god he just went in on that
[ __ ]
what was that an ostrich that [ __ ] to
pieces
[Music]
they're really just gonna [ __ ] steal
the rorschach line
is that rorjack yeah
it's birthday time i enjoy a man a few
words
oh bro you need to watch this damn that
honestly it looks like one of those
amazon like 200 budget movies
what do you think the budget for this
movie would have been the what
what do you think the budget for this
movie is
probably 50k that's what i'm guessing no
no no more than that because you got to
pay nicholas cage like
like at least a million right like isn't
his
his fee is probably still super high
yeah that's why i'm just gonna let you
kind of work this out out loud and then
you let me know what you think this
movie okay
that's fair okay so we got nicholas cage
i'm guessing his fee is probably a
million and a half
and then we have no other stars in this
movie so they
basically you know bottom of the barrel
for the rest of the actors just whoever
they could get right
like i'm just you know one of the actors
is a producer on this movie as well
just just so you know that okay got it
wait why are you why are you saying that
to me i'm just trying to give you
information you know to like make it
make a guess
okay so they probably acted for free
um let's see we have we have special
effects
and stuff like that so i'm gonna guess
you know 50k for that probably
probably shot this for like three weeks
and probably was like you know 500k i'm
gonna guess two and a half million
per budget let's try six
six million oh yeah
you know it's a great comparison
watching that movie
and then watching mandy which has nick
and his acting actually really works now
mandy pacing is
a little too slow i loved i liked the
movie but pacing was
very very slow but is that a is that a
reason you can last through both
that came out a couple years ago i've
talked about it on the podcast before
but if you watch both
back to back and you see what's possible
with six million dollars oh my god
so it's a it's just
you're like oh yeah okay all right all
right
what what do you think compels a casting
director
to cast nicholas cage as the lead in a
movie like this where you have six
million bucks
and you probably could get someone
better but
do you think he's so notorious do you
think his name's still like he's cheap
he's relatively cheap
compared to like other you know
a-listers
but you can still so you can still get
him and he's decent enough where you
have that star power so it'll drive
traffic but like you don't have to spend
a ton of money
yeah i think so now will this movie make
six million dollars
i don't think so but
but i think your your line of reasoning
is right
i also feel that nick he's seen it all
he did big best movies in the 90s and
early 2000s he did those big ass films
he's been rich before you know he might
i have a feeling it's not really about
prestige or money at this point i think
he's just
i think part of him is just [ __ ]
around he did
yeah he's done 10 movies in the last two
years
yeah [ __ ] ten and when you look at
what those movies are you're like
these are not anywhere close to each
other wait wait in terms of
what other ones have you done pull them
up pull them up pull them up i want to
see
this movie he did this movie recently
called jiu jitsu which i need to watch
it came out last year he's kind of like
who was bad grandpa
who's that actor again robert robert de
niro he's still
acting in just [ __ ] movies and it's like
dude you're a legend
you're why would you tarnish your
reputation like that like
the most recent one that he did is one
this year called what the [ __ ] is it
grandpa versus grandson vs grandpa or
some [ __ ] like that where like
they have a prank war it's so weird
this dude they're they're just so
they've done it all they're like who
gives a [ __ ]
yeah i'll do that [ __ ] movie yeah
just like being from
the camera cage just isn't doing [ __ ]
so when they tell them these crazy
movies they're like you want to do a
movie about
jiu-jitsu it's kind of a rip-off of
mortal kombat but you know it's going to
be guys doing jiu-jitsu
yeah sure he's like [ __ ] it how long is
filming
you name it i'll do it